mais pour démarrer à partir de ce soir
et pour 5 nuits la permanence du député
écologiste Charles Fournier va se
transformer en centre d'hébergement
d'urgence une démarche inédite pour
alerter les pouvoirs public les pouvoirs
publics sur la saturation du dispositif
actuel d'hébergement et qui pousse des
familles entières à dormir dehors 10
personnes sans abri dont cinq enfants
dormiront donc temporairement au chaud
boulevard heurtelou à tour sur place
Clémence d'osque assisté en fin
d'après-midi au dernier préparatif
regardez
quelques matelas des couvertures des
produits d'hygiène ainsi que des repas
chauds préparés par l'association la
table de jeannemarie Monsieur Fournier
bonsoir nous sommes dans votre
permanence qui a été transformé donc par
vos équipes ainsi que par le collectif
pas d'enfant à la rue en un hébergement
d'urgence pour accueillir une dizaine de
personnes à partir de ce soir donc faire
dormir des familles dans les écoles dans
une permance parce que le 115 sature
c'est normal de devoir en arriver là non
c évidemment pas normal nor ce n'est pas
une solution durable mais c'est une
manière d'interpeller les pouvoirs
publics l'État le gouvernement sur une
situation qui est inacceptable il doit y
avoir une Concorde de tout le monde sur
l'idée qu'aucun enfant ne doit pouvoir
dormir dans la rue dans notre pays c'est
une question d'honneur de notre pays
c'est une question de protection de
l'enfance donc ce soir à partir de ce
soir il y a CIN enfants accompagnés de
leur famille qui vont être éébergés ici
jusque lundi est-ce que vous vous ne
craignez pas que tout cela soit perçu en
fait comme une opération de
communication franchement j'ai aucun
intérêt à communiquer à titre personnel
si c'est le sens de votre question c'est
une opération de communication par
ailleurs pour dire ce n'est pas normal
cette situation je je je je je veux à
travers ça montrer que ces personnes ont
besoin de solution et que on est obligé
d'employer toutes des solutions qui n'en
sont pas parce que euh aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d'hébergement d'urgence tous
les amendements qui étaient proposés
pour augmenter le nombre de places
d'accueil d'urgence ont été rejetés
c'est cette situation situation qu'il
faut dénoncer et pas l'idée que j'en
ferais une communication à titre
personnel je ne gagne rien à faire ça
mais par contre c'est un combat
collectif c'est un combat d'humanisme
c'est un combat pour la justice et pour
que ces enfants
ent un toit c'est je crois notre devoir
donc comme vous le dites c'est un devoir
collectif et tout le monde s'accorde sur
le fait qu'on ne peut pas laisser des
enfants dormir à la rue mais par exemple
à tour du moins tour métropole un
logement sur 10 et vacant qu'est-ce que
vous vous pouvez faire est est-ce que
vous pouvez les faire réquésitionner à
titre à titre de député je ne peux pas
le faire par contre je peux le demander
je peux demander d'abord qu'il y ait des
moyens pour les places d'urgence parce
qu'il faut que cet accueil soit
structurant évidemment ce n'est pas
suffisant mais il va falloir trouver des
solutions durables il faut changer les
règles aussi sur le plan le plan hiver
vous voyez c le seuil des 1°gr les
questions des intempéries est-ce que ces
règles-là sont justes quand on est à la
rue qu'on soit à moins 1 degr qu'il ait
du vent de la pluie ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas satisfaisant donc je crois que
qu'il faut faire évoluer ces règles et
puis enfin si toutes ces solutions là ne
permettent pas de répondre à l'accueil
oui il faut réquisitionner des bâtiments
des logements qui sont vides pour
accueillir ces famillesl dans les
situations d'urgence que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui monsieur
Fournier merci nous nous allons devoir
nous éclipser parce que les familles
vont commencer à arriver pour Rael à
tour une quarantaine d'enfants n'ont pas
de solution d'hébergement ce soir ils
sont au moins cinq à pouvoir dormir au
chauff I